so ist es und heute mit einem aufreger
der was mit journalismus zu tun hat der
bild hat was unglaubliches gemacht in
den beginnenden sondierungsgesprächen
wir und vor allen dingen mein kollege
paul ronzheimer hat einfach berichtet
hat berichtet über das was da hinter
verschlossenen türen passiert ist handy
alarm haben wir das getauft bei bild
aber es sagt nichts anderes als dass
paul informationen bekommen hat aus
diesen vertraulichen sitzungen und diese
an sie weitergegeben hat und sie jetzt
garantien nämlich diese hier
eingeblendet sehen die
bildungsministerin von schleswig
holstein und sie war ja auch in zukunft
team von armin laschet die will dem
ganzen ein ende bereiten klar die ist
total genervt davon dass ihre
parteikollegen immer so viel
informationen weitergeben aber sie
möchte das radikal beendet indem sie
sagt weg mit dem mobiltelefon aus
vertraulichen sitzung und zwar sofort
also sie möchte ein handy verbot für
ihre cdu-kollegen und cdu kolleginnen
durchsetzen das ist mehr grünen politik
als unionspolitik verbotspolitik die
karin prien da durchsetzen möchte und
ich sage das ist vor allem eins das ist
peinlich für die eigenen reihen denn es
zeigt wie groß das misstrauen ist bei
der union da traut der eine dem anderen
nicht mehr am tisch und das einzige was
garantien einfällt ist am ende zu sagen
weg mit den handys handy verbot für alle
methoden wie in der schule die die union
dazu erziehen sollen nicht mehr so
misstrauisch sich selbst gegenüber zu
sein ein unglaubliche forderung die da
aus schleswig holstein kommt die aus der
cdu kommt und die wie gesagt nur eines
verdeutlicht das unglaubliche misstrauen
im moment in der cdu
dass das bestätigt auch so ein bisschen
was misstrauen was in der bevölkerung
entstanden es gegenüber der politik auch
gegenüber der cdu und ich meine hier
schule erstens zweitens ist es auch ein
einschnitt in die journalistische
freiheit um außerdem ist ja auch der
verdacht oder dieser dieses dieser
vorwurf in der politik dass alles immer
hinter verschlossenen türen geschieht
das immer dass mein vater mir gesagt ja
die die reden da immer irgendwie
irgendwas im hinterzimmer gesprächen und
man erfährt dass irgendwie ähnlich und
natürlich verstehe ich es wenn man als
politiker ob man vertrauliche gespräche
führen will muss man ja auch um sich
geschlossen auch besprechen zu können
und um auch mal diesen denkprozess
anzustoßen aber dass karin prien jetzt
beschlossen oder angestossen hat finde
ich schon sehr lächerlich es ist ja auch
absolut naiv also wenn ich handyverbot
in einer sitzung habe gibt in der
heutigen zeit so viele
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten vielleicht
auch nach einer sitzung also auch das zu
glauben dass das nur innerhalb einer
sitzung geht also das ist naiv karin
prien hat natürlich in diesem beitrag
auch gesagt und das spricht am ende dann
auch wieder ein bisschen für sie das
natürlich das was da gerade passiert
viel aussagt über den zustand ihrer
eigenen partei und wir sehen es ist eine
die erodierende die machtverhältnisse
sehr interessant dass bei spd grünen und
fdp parteien die jetzt bei der
bundestagswahl mehr oder weniger sehr
erfolgreich abgeschnitten haben diese
dinge nicht passieren aber dass wir es
bei der union sehen wo einfach jetzt und
die macht erodiert und diese partei muss
sich erstmal selbst finden und selbst
suchen und dabei muss man vielleicht
auch den frustfaktor den karin prien
gerade hat nicht ganz außer acht lassen
kann prima mitglied des zukunftsteams
karin prien wurde immer schon auch als
ministerin gehandelt wäre sicherlich
auch gerne bundesministerin geworden ein
kabinett von armin laschet kann es nicht
werden jetzt gibt es sogar erste stimmen
die sagen ja kein team soll neue
generalsekretärin der cdu werden also
möglicherweise und da will ich niemand
verdächtigen aber kommt diese
information sogar aus ihrem eigenen
umfeld also vielleicht lässt sich das
sogar streuen weiß ich nicht wie ich das
ding auch nicht mutmaßt aber interessant
das ist noch gar keinen neuen parteichef
gibt aber eine neue generalsekretärin
offenbar schon im gespräch ist also das
ist ja wirklich als wenn der hund mit
dem schwanz bild man sieht karin prien
ist frustriert wer gerne mehr geworden
und so buch ich das ab als totale
frustration ich würde teilte so leider
half nicht ich finde also was ich fand's
in einer ganzen nation hinz mit ich hab
dich doch nicht gewählt
haben sie jetzt
ja denn die so laden laufen nicht mehr
olaf scholz gewählt einmal urlaub
sparbuch
21 5 ist raus was ich sagen wollte was
ich fand für merkel im grunde sich
zurückziehen merkt man dass es auch
immer schon stimmen gab die sich
hervortun wollen die jetzt irgendwie nie
gehört wurden oder zumindest jetzt erst
diese aufmerksamkeit stelle bekommen und
das ist genau das das ding ist dass die
machtverhältnisse sich jetzt gerade
einfach verändern und noch gar nicht so
ganz klar ist wer da am ende auch die
aufmerksamkeit
aufmerksamkeitsspanne auch langfristig
halten kann aber
wir können nur abwarten und wir wissen
nicht was in vier fünf monaten oder
generell die cdu-opposition für menschen
hervorbringt die jetzt jahrelang ich sag
mal eher still waren uns sich
zurückgehalten und misstrauen ist
natürlich keine unions phänomen das muss
man auch mal ehrlich sagen wo vertraut
man sich eigentlich hier im politischen
berlin wenn es wirklich hart auf hart
kommt also nehmen wir dieses elfi was
wir gesehen haben zwischen fdp und
grünen das soll ja vertrauen
symbolisieren fast eine
freundschaftliche atmosphäre daran im
dienstagabend nach der wahl und wenn man
jetzt aber sich eine situation spitz auf
knopf vorstellen würde ob irgendjemand
von den vieren dem nachbar auf dem foto
auch nur eine sekunde über den weg traut
sie würde ich sehr zweifel ziehen
arbeiten einfach dieses diese art von
vertrauen nicht es gibt gemeinsame
interessen und deswegen hält man bei der
fdp im moment auch still deswegen hält
man bei den grünen im moment auch still
aber eben nur so lange wie man die
selben interessen hat das ändert sich
sofort wenn die fdp dann tatsächlich auf
dem ampel kurs ist wenn man über
steuererhöhungen mit der spd diskutieren
muss und so weiter da entgleitet das
dann auch und bei der spd ganz genauso
mit norbert walter borjans und saskia
esken die laufen sie sich jetzt schon
warm haben jetzt schon die handynummer
von paul rausgesucht um denn als er auf
die schöne steigerung feind todfeind
parteifreund
so ist es
aber wir müssen hier glaube ich schon
mal sagen nicht jeder das schon so ein
bisschen an so früher in der schule wenn
irgendwie ich dreimal aufgeführt wurde
weil ich wieder zu viel zeit ich mit
meiner nachbarin geschrieben habe sind
nachbarn ihren ich meinen beruf und ich
meine wir reden hier über hohe politik
und jetzt soll es ein handyverbot geben
das ist für mich ein thema was auf
deutschland schulhöfen herrscht wenn der
lehrer mal richtig irgendwie die auf den
tisch lege und sagt jetzt reicht's mit
euren hennes alle handy weg und dann die
eltern auch hinlaufen pausen sagen
können sie meinem sohn das handy
wegnehmen das ist ein recht von ihm also
ich finde es für die politik schon sehr
peinlicher liberale parteifreunde anja
stellt sie unter generalverdacht das
muss keine aussage also das muss man
sich dann mal bitten lassen wenn man da
irgendwie 20 oder 30 jahre im parlament
auch sitzt in dem fall ein ganz
ähnlicher
parteifreund ist oder eine parteifreunde
ist und dann kommt jemand aus
deutschland sagt böse böse ich gesagt
alle unter generalverdacht und deswegen
ab jetzt wohin die aus metall so rauber
hat er ich stelle mir so zauberhaft vor
montags sitzung des cdu-präsidiums
wolfgang schäuble volker bouffier
michael kretschmer aus sagt seien die
ganzen kranken fahren vor und dann steht
vorne fahren oder die generalsekretär
und sammelt erst mal die handys mit dem
körbchen aber man kann darauf setzen
ohne handy oder ich habe da auch kein
handy dabei und kann dann irgendwas
setzen was wir hier gesagt hast ja dass
der bund die sitzung vorbei also aber
karin prien hat in ihrer karriere auch
immer davon profitiert natürlich dass
sie dinge auch mit journalisten
die sagen einfach mal ganz neutral
geteilt hat und natürlich ist es wichtig
und das ist der anspruch von
journalisten dass wir dinge
herausbekommen es geht am ende ja darum
wer will deutschland regieren und es ist
pflicht von journalisten aufzuklären
auch zu schauen gerade dorthin wo man
versucht informationen fernzuhalten von
der öffentlichkeit genau da hinzuschauen
und zu sagen also passiert da etwas was
uns ein bisschen komisch vorkommen
müssen wir dann noch näher hinschauen
von daher ist es eigentlich eine
verkehrung der tatsachen
und die ist dem eigenen frust den tropf
prämienschub geschuldet aber der handy
alarm ist halt auch er sorgt schon sehr
für furore das handy ja also ich meine
deutschlandfunk hat jetzt auch geschaut
wie das jetzt mit dem handy alarm ist ob
das jetzt gut ist für die demokratie und
wer sich schon relativ witzig wie viele
handy alarm auslöst beim journalismus
ist ja schon eingangs dass der
deutschlandfunk jetzt gucken will ob das
gut ist für demokratie das wundert mich
wieder mal
also 300 nicht überhaupt nicht kennen
die alle über ihn aber deutschlandfunk
ich habe nur gedacht dass völler weiter
daran für ein großteil der journalisten
ist dass wir nicht ausschließlich warten
auf verlautbarungen auf die gäste
stellten haben pressemitteilung sondern
dass wir sehr nachrichten ja das zeug
für den restaurant
ist jetzt eigentlich nur ein symbol
dafür was sowieso überall passiert oder
läuft es ist ja eigentlich die arbeit
von einem politik journalisten an
journalisten dran sein um zu erfahren
was wirklich in den sitz und abgelaufen
ist und das bin ich halt auch sehr
witzig des carlin sich darüber
echauffiert das heißt eigentlich für
mich ist sie sich schon auch über den
journalismus einem sehe er zwar später
noch mal richtig gestellt es ginge um
die unions politiker aber so ich mag das
handy von paul ich finde es immer sehr
witzig war anderen kollegen ist es
möglicherweise der neid dass diese
kolleginnen und kollegen die ihre
informationen selbst nicht haben und
davor offenbar entweder toten handys
oder ausgeschalteten handys oder türen
stehen durch die sie nicht kommen dass
das muss man einfach so sehen aber die
debatte darum ob das jetzt gut oder
schlecht für die demokratie und für die
freiheit ist das ist wirklich die
absurdeste debatte des jahres also dass
informationen das licht der welt
erblicken über die frage was wird in dem
runden diskutiert wenn es um die zukunft
von deutschland geht das ist das darauf
hat jeder der 82 millionen bundesbürger
ein anrecht kann war die eingereicht
könnte man die verhandlungen eigentlich
komplett transparent für leisten könnte
könnte man das machen es wäre doch ein
wahnsinnig faszinierende ansatz hat ja
jetzt wie sie blauer verkauft oder was
machen die da konstruieren die jetzt
daraus ich glaube es passiert einfach
gar nichts also die karin prien setzt
ihr in die verbote nicht durch und die
informationen werden weiter aufs handy
laden
sein
[Musik]